(crowd chanting in Chinese)
- [Narrator] People across
China are not happy.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)
- [Narrator] And their anger exploded
on the streets for several days.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)
From residents fed up with
lockdowns in far West China.
(people speaking in Chinese)
- [Narrator] To students
at prestigious universities in Beijing.
Nearly three years into
the pandemic, protestors
from different walks of life
have been pushed to the brink,
a mid strict COVID controls
that have hurt livelihoods
and stifled the economy.
(crowd shouting in Chinese)
- [Narrator] Here's how one
of the largest nationwide demonstrations
in decades happened in China,
and how this fury creates
a political dilemma
for Xi Jinping's leadership.
The anger was sparked by a fire
in an apartment building
on Thursday in Urumqi,
capital of the northwestern
region of Xinjiang
where officials said 10 people died.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)
- [Narrator] The next day, residents upset
by the deadly fire took their
frustrations to the streets,
having also struggled with lockdowns
for more than three months.
They said COVID restrictions
like barriers had delayed rescuers.
Officials said parked cars got
in the way of moving more quickly.
On Saturday, in a show of solidarity,
people in Shanghai held a vigil
to mourn victims of the fire.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)
- [Narrator] By the evening,
larger groups began gathering
on a road named after
Urumqi, which became a center
of protests that followed
in the next few days.
(dramatic music)
As the demonstrations expanded,
a call for change became louder.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)
- [Narrator] That China's
strict pandemic measures
be rolled back.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)
- [Narrator] By Sunday, as protests spread
to other major cities,
some of the demands turned political.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)
- [Narrator] And pointed
directly at President Xi Jinping.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)
- [Narrator] blank sheets of
paper also began popping up
at demonstrations to
symbolize protestors' defiance
against censorship.
While censors worked quickly
to remove any indication
of unrest on Chinese
social media platforms,
officials set out to
quash any new protests.
On Monday, the government deployed scores
of officers and police cars
lined the streets of Beijing.
Plastic barriers went up
along the road where the first protests
outside of Xinjiang began.
Chinese state media also
published commentaries
defending Xi's zero COVID approach,
saying the policy is essential
for protecting lives.
Though the streets are quieter
and some pandemic measures
in Xinjiang and Beijing
have eased since Sunday,
these protests present a conundrum
for Xi who just secured a
norm-breaking third term
and runs a regime focused on stability.
If he relaxes COVID restrictions,
that could lead to a
new wave of infections,
and a possible spike in
deaths among a large part
of the elderly population
that isn't vaccinated.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)
But if he holds steadfast,
it could create deeper grievances
against his leadership.
(crowd chanting in Chinese)